well Mohammed gem Jun is in cave for us
and Mohammed what more can you tell us
about these Russian strikes on Ukrainian
soil
well Tom we've heard yet again in the
past 10 minutes or so from Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski he is now
updating citizens throughout the country
saying that there are 1.5 million
Ukrainian households without power at
this hour and he's saying that as a
result of these massive Russian strikes
that hit practically every region of
this country much earlier today and let
me try to break down what happened
earlier in the day for you more than 10
Ukrainian regions experienced widespread
power outages as a result of these
Russian missile strikes the national
Energy company ukranergo they had issued
a statement a couple of hours ago saying
that the latest attacks may have caused
worse damage to the power infrastructure
and the power grid in this country than
the barrage of missiles that hit various
Ukrainian cities on October 10th and if
you'll remember October 10th was the day
there had been the largest attack on
this country from Russia since the
beginning of the War this past February
now some of the regions that have been
impacted by the missile strikes today
include rivney that's in the west of the
country also ludsk that's in the west of
the country we're told large portions of
Luz are without power and that's because
a critical infrastructure facility there
was destroyed by missiles that struck it
earlier in the day also Odessa in the
South Sumi in the north and in the
center of the country Kiev region which
is where the capital key where we are
now is located and kirov in the center
of the country as well now as a result
of all of this there have been
restrictions to the electricity Supply
that have been imposed throughout the
day by the National Power Company
throughout all of these regions there is
a lot of concern that there will be more
blackouts in the days ahead and we were
also told by Ukrainian president's
office that there were a total of 18
missiles destroyed today by air defense
systems out of a total of 33 missiles
that were fired into Ukraine Tom okay
what more can you tell us about uh these
evacuations uh in uh Curson that uh
Russian occupational authorities are
asking civilians to leave immediately
well there hasn't been a lot of updates
on that from the Ukrainian side and the
reason for that Tom is because there has
effectively been a media blackout in
place when it comes to the Ukrainian
counter-offensive and what the Ukrainian
forces are doing to try to recapture
their son this has been in place for
close to a week now I can tell you that
when watching media figures here when
hearing from certain politicians there
is a sense that these folks are
indicating that they believe that the
Ukrainian forces are steadily advancing
that there is a belief here in Ukraine
that the Ukrainian forces will be
successful in recapturing at least part
of Herson but again it is a media
blackout we're not getting any kind of
uh logistical updates tactical updates
when it comes to the movement of
Ukrainian forces we know from videos
that we've seen uh purporting to show
what's going on in Harrison that
evacuations being carried out out by the
Russians are still taking place we've
seen these videos we can't independently
verify them we know that there is
concern among the ukrainians because
they don't call them evacuations in
Ukraine they say this this forced
displacement so there was a lot of
concern about what will happen to these
citizens who are being evacuated we
heard from Russian officials a few days
ago they said that up to 60 000 people
may be evacuated by the Russians into
the Russian side it seems as though now
this is a much more dire warning from
the Russians to try to evacuate
residents as urgently as possible Tom
okay thank you very much for that update
that is Muhammad Jim June for us and
cave
well the governor of Russia's Belgard
region says two civilians have been
killed by shelling or 15 000 people have
been left without electricity after
strikes on the region bordering Ukraine
Ukraine has denied responsibility for
several attacks carried out there since
Russia's Invasion began in February
let's go to Muhammad Val in Moscow now
and what more can you uh tell us about
this
yes Tom uh just as my colleague Muhammad
mentioned about the blackout with
regards to the specifics and the details
of what happens at the front line we
also here have a similar situation the
ministry of Defense in its Daily
Briefing talks about the casualties or
the the damage it inflicts on a daily
basis
among the Ukrainian soldiers speaking
today about 130 soldiers killed
somewhere and another 80 killed between
Herson and the liman axes in different
in different contexts uh trying also to
a tell the population here the people of
Russia that the the military are doing
what they should do to push back the
Ukrainian offensive uh at any occasion
in Belgrade this has become a daily
reality the the daily shelling and the
ukrainians are not talking about it but
the Russians on every occasion they
accuse the Ukrainian side of being
behind those attacks uh three days four
days ago there was an attack on a an oil
Depot and also an attack on a power
station that caused a blackout in the
city they said it was mended uh very
quickly but apparently from the reports
today the local authorities the
pro-russian local authorities there have
acknowledged that 15 000 people have
gone without electricity and two people
died as you mentioned so that City
because of that town because it's very
close to the Border it is only 40
kilometers from the border with Ukraine
the the usual border with Ukraine before
the annexation of that part of the land
and also it is one hour drive from
kharkiv which is the Ukraine's second
largest city so it's very vulnerable
it's very very close in the range of the
Ukrainian Ruckus and sometimes Ukraine
used in the past it used helicopters
even to attack locations there and
infrastructure so that City in
particular is very vulnerable as I said
and the Russians are seemingly
apparently unable to protect it the same
applies with the population of Carson as
you mentioned there that evacuation is
going on and today it has reached an
excessive limit when they said everyone
should leave and that is seen by the
Russian side as a measure to protect the
population but on the Ukrainian side
it's seen as a transfer of civilians
okay thank you so much that is uh
Muhammad Val for us in Moscow